even before the first ballot was cast
many political commentators have been
predicting victory for the ruling
liberal democratic party or ldp
it's ruled japan almost without
interruption since the end of the second
world war it enters the polls with high
approval rating and a fragmented
opposition is thought to offer little
competition
these polls take place just two days
after former prime minister shinzo abe
was assassinated in nara city while
campaigning
abe who was a member of the lower house
and head of the ldp's largest faction
still wielded considerable influence and
his assassination may result in sympathy
votes for the party
i think abe has thought a lot about this
country and i hope this election can
make his efforts worthwhile
there may be more people who will vote
for the liberal democratic party the
assassination was a shocking incident so
i think people have many thoughts but i
hope they can vote based on their own
decision
a surge of support will help prime
minister fumio kishida strengthen his
grip on power
generally speaking his polls are quite
high
but one thing which is dogging him is
the rising inflation and cost of living
as it is many in many nations of the
world if the the results tonight
are at or above expectations then i
think we can definitely say that kishi's
position will be secured for quite some
time going forward
it may even see the ldp and its junior
coalition partner komeito controlling
two-thirds of parliament which would
allow them to take the first steps in
amending the constitution
one of abe's goals had been to revise
the country's pacifist constitution
which forbids japan's offensive military
capabilities
meanwhile the suspect in the murder of
abe has been handed over to prosecutors
in nara where he will likely be detained
and questioned before being charged
police have acknowledged there were
security flaws in friday's incident and
have promised a thorough investigation
florence louis al jazeera